we are on our last overtime of the air
for Rebecca is there any connection
between domestic violence and terrorism
yeah a very firm connection in fact I
can't remember the percentage of mass
shooters who are and terrorists who have
domestic violence in their past also
animal cruelty it's always a capacitive
right it's actually one of the things
that leaked that links everything from
DOMA allowing people to kill elephants
and then send their parts back all of it
all of it yeah violence against women
and mass violence should we and and are
we able to rethink president Trump's
access to the nuclear football
well no president I mean that's sort of
like architecture though in place don't
you think with all those generals around
or maybe this is a fantasy of mine but
don't you think John Kelly and mattis
and these people have discussed that he
can't absolutely our discussion yes
among people in the White House who have
concerns about the president's quote
temperament and what to do in moments
when that temperament seems out of whack
and knowledge he only well that's the
other only this year seemed to discover
that nuclear weapons were bad look
nobody knew if the repertory olfactory
in terms of what he knows about what
goes on in the world the history in the
United States it is really extraordinary
and it's again it's a fact that we've
never had a president who knows less
about the history of his country about
what goes on in the world around him
this is extraordinary
it doesn't mean though that he doesn't
have good instincts as Chiefs had good
enough instincts to win the presidency
I'm not making a psychiatric these
generals have gotten together and said
we cannot have a him I allow him to have
access to the nuclear code anything
I don't think it could do that I think
they can say like if the order comes and
we know it's that crazy we just don't do
it distract him with a cheeseburger
secure there is the National Security
Council there are the chairman of the
Joint Chiefs there are and by the way
missiles are not just ready to fly they
know if you only have to be targeted
there is that's why we have the defense
condition right here now at DEFCON five
we would have to go all the way down
DEFCON one launch a nuclear weapon and
the reason we have those defense
conditions is to give the grown-ups time
to intervene
bill your new book is about Vermont
seceding from the United States you
think the idea will catch on well
probably not in Vermont I mean it's more
plot device we're an old state and
saying Social Security will go away
might be enough to bring us to heal but
I never quite understand California I
mean this is 40 million people it's an
economy the size of Germany and you've
got the same two senators that we've got
in Vermont for 600,000 new coats that's
so wrong I mean that we're glad that you
stay because the countries were screwed
without you but yeah I know a lot of the
country things Jesus personally handed
the constitution of the founding fathers
but it needs a page-one rewrite that
Constitution it really does I mean
there's some great things in it and
there's some [ __ ] that really has to go
we also don't teach civics in school we
don't teach kids the reason that that's
rare was for a very good reason because
back in the day there was no California
the biggest most powerful state was
slave-owning Virginia and you didn't
want Virginia running roughshod over
tiny little Vermont and so that's why we
have the money of every state Vermont
didn't even join in for 15 years we were
an independent republic too we became
the fourteenth state and that's one of
the reasons that it's you know that that
resistance spirit the spirit of Mr
Sanders whoever stays pretty strong
that's right he's still an independent
okay what pressures do the government or
big corporations put on journalists to
not report information they do not want
exposed not usually very successful
there was a lot of like rumors about
like Muller hiding information or having
the mainstream media had all this
information about you know the Panama
papers and all like investigation
details that they said they held back on
purpose the mainstream media is that a
real thing or is that something I don't
know the specifics but I cannot imagine
that once having had those papers the
Panama papers and then doing the
necessary checking and reporting and
follow-through I can't imagine any
responsible news organization
go with the information in them today's
story though is that the Koch brothers
were about to by Time magazine write the
list of things that are owned by
Murdoch's and cokes and things just
keeps growing well that brings us to
citizens united isn't that something if
we get the right people elected and
Democrats in office and women in office
whether they are I mean don't you think
that is something I know we have the
like you know a different leaning bench
right now for the Supreme Court but that
is something that takes everybody's
money out of politics and if we had
publicly funded elections I know that
seems like a long shot except the most
powerful members of the donor class who
determined who don't want to give five
dollars to every candidate they like or
you know I mean why don't we have it I
mean that's something worth discussing
and actually are entertaining as an idea
moving fine that's the danger of
forgetting rid of the Johnson Act this
is something that we're not discussing
if we get rid of the Johnson Act which
separates church and state because
remember religions are international and
a lot of countries have state religions
and if you get rid of the Johnson Act
there is nothing to stop Vladimir Putin
giving a billion dollars a Russian
Orthodox Church which will then donate
it through an American Russian Orthodox
Church to the candidate of their choice
and we didn't get to the topic of the
tax bill which is pretty big today but I
mean that is a bill written for the
donor class that's why they want to keep
the situation as a plutocracy it is and
what we have been developing over the
past thirty thirty five years in this
country particularly through tax and and
economic inequality and and the middle
class falling farther behind here's a
kind of plutocracy that we've never had
in this country since the Gilded Age and
it really is the great domestic
political question there no longer is of
what are we gonna do about this they're
not even trying to hide it I mean
today's news was no tax exemptions for
teachers buying classroom supplies yes
tax exemptions for private jets
so has said this is because if we don't
get are the donors will dry up we won't
get money Chris Collins this
representative from New Jersey has said
the same thing there
openly admitting that they have to pass
these tax cuts for the super-rich
robbing the middle class and the poor so
that they can keep getting their money
together do you if that's who you work
for
that's who you work for that's right all
right last question of the year what do
who do you see stepping up to the plate
in 2018 and 2020 to lead the Democrats
to victory all of us we did this in 2008
we elected Obama and in Obama and it was
yes weekend yes and in his speech he
said listen now the hard work rides and
we all said okay benevolent king go fix
everything we're gonna discover Netflix
and tinder yeah we can't do that comes
from the bottom it comes from us we
responsible
[Music]
you